good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
hump day it is very appropriate that it
is hump day because it's my favorite day
of the week
week it's theo's favorite day of the
week and today he's humping someone he
really admires and is completely in love
with seeing look at theo he's never been
so happy in his life
because we are joined by tyler cameron
today hello tyler hello hello thank you
for having me
thank you so much for being here welcome
back to the show this time in a more
official capacity we're putting you to
work
last time you got evicted this place is
beautiful thank you so much you've now
been to two of our studios
you like this one better or the other
one don't lie this one this one's nice
you sure i came in it's beautiful you
got the the sign up look at this
wallpaper
wallpaper is nice it's decorated like
the bachelor mansion
well you're coming at us here today not
as a reality star
not as all the things that you are
but as an accomplished author an author
yeah my book comes out july 27th i'm
very excited for that
it's called you deserve better tell me a
little bit about why a book
and what people can expect from this um
why a book to talk crap to my
english teachers back in high school who
said i couldn't read or write
but for real though uh you know we were
talking about a book after the show
and um i was like what am i going to
write about right now i don't have
anything to write about then i just kind
of really sat back and thought about it
and i was seeing how i was kind of
getting praised for all these things
on this show as like this feminist icon
and this respectful world king and all
these things like
marie claire wrote a article about
master's class on consent that i gave
all these things i was like i didn't do
anything special right
i did what i hope my little brothers
would do what my friends would do like i
feel like i'd do like the bare minimum
you know and so to me i was like well
there's an issue and so i was like you
know what this may be
this is kind of what we can write off of
and so that's kind of what we went for
and i dove into it i learned a lot doing
it and it was it was a good experience
and i love that you have a little insert
in the middle with photos i have the
same thing and these are
really premium photos i suggest getting
the hard copy lots of uh tyler c behind
the scenes really um
you're very photogenic you gotta get the
gotta get the books you can see the
photos yeah the hardcover is everything
i did the audiobook
and i realized the next book if i do
next book it's just going to be a
picture book because i'm
the reading it was rough what about a
coloring book uh coloring book would be
good too you can just color me in how
long did it take you i remember it was
it's so hot in that room it's so boring
too
oh three days yeah seven eight hours a
day it was rough
it was rough for sure your neck hurts
your throat hurts everything hurts
so who is this book for like who do you
want to read this what do you want the
message to be
this book is for anybody and everybody
this book is for women and men
uh you know it's for your friend who you
think is going to get a bad relationship
it's for like my like i say like to my
little brothers like this is how we need
to be treating
women better your significant other
better and for women to realize like you
know we need to be treated better and
and to kind of see like red flags and
things that are good and bad in
relationships yeah
and you're in a relationship now was
that a source of inspiration for the
book
uh no i actually wrote this book and
finished it before i met her
wow she's not in the book i'm kidding
but no
has that been a fight between you guys
no no no no but i will say like like
you know we were going you know we've
been doing we've gone through things as
a relationship and i was like i was
reading my book
and i was like calling myself out for
things right you know so it was like a
good self-check
on it and uh you know it's easy to
preach it but it's harder to do it and
then i was like reading i was like damn
i need to walk and talk it yeah yeah
so what's the key message like someone
who's either not great at dating or is
having trouble in a relationship what do
you think is like one of the key
takeaways
from your book that you want people to
talk a lot about rejection too
and because because i feel like when you
keep putting yourself out there and
dating you're going to get rejected
there's going to be rejection but i
think rejection
has always been a beautiful thing for me
it's always led me to my best
you know the real housewives of new
jersey siggy flicker once said
a man's rejection is god's protection
yeah i i
probably agree with that one yeah a
woman's rejection too sometimes but uh
that's true but uh no i mean i think uh
for me it's just like i've been i've had
my you know
events where i've came up short you know
whether it's dating whether it's
football whether whatever it is but it's
always guided me to a better direction
and so like in dating you're gonna get
rejected you're gonna you're gonna it's
not gonna work out for you but
keep going you're gonna learn every time
you do it yeah well the book's available
on the 27th of july which is like
literally in a few days
yes and it's available audiobook ebook
hardcover all the places
all the good stuff and there's pictures
in the middle honestly pictures are my
favorite part of a book it's my favorite
part the only thing i rolled through
i know you're headed on a flight after
this i do have an extra copy of my book
if you want to i have pictures in there
too
like people seem to like it um i'm so
glad you're here i'm so excited that
you're in the city and that we're able
to do this we have a great show
not only is tyler going to be breaking
down the fast five stories with me even
though
i'm not sure what what is your
involvement in pop culture
and pop culture uh very little i got
updated on everything before i got here
right right right
but and do you find that you know more
or less about pop culture since
your recent somewhat recent rise to fame
because now it's like you could open a
magazine
and you could be in it i was definitely
under like a a whole like a rocket under
a rock that's the term when i did my
first you know before the show
and now this rock has cracked open a
little bit so i'm starting to get some
stuff but still
totally not you know in with the pop
culture what are you passionate about
sports
sports what do you think about giannis
giannis we want he won the mvp
you know i was i was a big win for him i
was thinking no now i can leave
the blocks but we're not here to talk
about basketball no i mean i do talk
about basketball because i don't know if
you guys know this i'm not like other
girls
but um you know i just it's nice to find
common ground and you know there's a lot
of
a lot of people don't know there's a big
amount of crossover between pop culture
and sports
so many celebrities dating sports
players kroy biermann and kim biermann
there's a lot
to there's a lot of parallels and i just
think that's important and worth noting
i agree
yeah i don't know who kroy biermann and
something biermann is okay so
i'll tell you kim biermann was on the
real housewives of atlanta and she was
kind of like this breakout
star because she was kind of chaotic you
know um she
had a relationship with someone who she
kept anonymous named him big papa turns
out he was married
she was this very tumultuous journey for
her and then she met kroy biermann
who played for the atlanta falcons and
she was a real housewife of atlanta so
it was just kind of this like atlanta
royal couple i don't know if everyone
would agree with that but i do
and they had a thousand children and
they got their own show called don't be
tardy which only recently got canceled
but it did go for eight seasons but it's
a huge loss for the community for sure
and then it was all this drama with
kroy's football because he was pretty
good but he got traded to the bills
and then like a day into working on the
bills they like fired him and then he
never played in the nfl again
so that's the extent of my football
knowledge okay we last long on the
bill's on do with the ravens so that's
good
oh right you did play football um what
was that like
it was good it was good like i said i
had a i basically had a cup of coffee
with the ravens and i said
get out of here kid was it good coffee
it was it wasn't good coffee no no they
didn't give me the good stuff just like
border black and out blacking out okay
well at least you got there
exactly it's truly like the journey not
the destination exactly
rejection it was a good rejection
exactly and then you want to be here i
wouldn't be here if it wasn't
like the 11th most watched podcast
exactly 11. it's like
12. um okay so i want to dive into
everything
with tyler c um so get ready for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's sponsor it's fresh from san
diego california the only sunglass brand
we're ever going to wear again
blender's eyewear and you're going to be
just as hook when you hooked
when you see how awesome these shades
are i've been in the need for new
prescription glasses because at night i
can't really see the tv
i got the heart rush style and i've been
wearing ben's glasses for the last two
years and i'm finally
i'm feeling really good about having my
own pair they're kind of stunning and
they came really fast
um chase fisher started blenders by
selling his beachy
shades out of his backpack while
doubling as a surf instructor on pacific
beach
unlike expensive big brand shades that
you've probably lost or smashed in the
past
blenders are actually affordable so
you're not going to cry as much when the
inevitable inevitable
happens blender's team of in-house
designers are constantly coming out with
new styles
from orange polarized wraparounds
tortoise shell frames with purple lenses
to classic gold arms on black lenses and
it's not just sunglasses they have
prescription
glasses readers blue lights as well as a
snow collection with goggles and
accessories
live life in forward motion with
blenders to score 15
off of your blender's purchase visit
blenderseyeware.com
and enter promo code toastbip that's
blenderseyewear.com
code toastvip for 15 off blenders
rocked with pride worldwide we love a
slogan that rhymes
all right first up i'm not gonna lie
there wasn't a lot going on in the world
today so we're really scraping the
bottom of the barrel for news but that's
what we do here at the morning toast to
scrape the bottom of the barrel
but according to vulture kanye west has
confirmed his dondo release date with a
beats ad
starring shikari richardson so there's
been a lot of
hoopla about when kanye will release his
next album but they did this little
commercial
for beats by dry star jakari richardson
who was the olympian the runner that
everyone was like obsessed with
and then she didn't end up running
because she tested positive for
marijuana and it was like all this drama
but
now she's kind of a star kanye west has
confirmed the release date of his latest
album donda
the way god intended via an ad for beats
by dre headphones
donda is set to drop this friday one day
after the upcoming live streamed
live streamed album listening event in
atlanta on july 22nd
so there's a lot to unpack here one is
that we're getting a new kanye west
album are you a kanye west fan
i like his old stuff big big fan not
into the
the gospel i just haven't really
listened to it now it's pretty good i'm
not gonna lie and i'm jewish but i love
listening to
catholic christian music all right all
right what religion are you
is that root ask no i'm christian your
christian do you listen to christian
music
no it's really good yeah there's this
girl
francesca battistelli i might be
pronouncing that wrong
and she does like a lot of as far as i
know i've obviously never been to church
but
i think it's like very popular in the
youth groups and it's really
it's a bop and she's talking about god
but if you're if you're not you know
listening to it under that you could
think of it like
she's talking about a boyfriend but
she's really talking about the lord so
you switch it up for yourself yeah for
me even though i'm married but like
still like
i couldn't be thinking about it it's
about my man yeah it's actually
really good music i know you're going on
a long flight so if you need a playlist
i could send you my
christian music playlist um okay but i
wanted to ask you about what your
thoughts on shikari richardson are did
you keep up with the olympics tyler
scott a little bit a little bit yes
and i think it's uh amazing that you
know she it sucks what happened to her
with
not being able to run in the olympics
but it's amazing that she's still
getting tons of opportunities
yes to become a circle she's a star yeah
i thought sorry no no no no no i just
kind of
like for her to get that deal with dre
and and kanye it's a big deal and
fabulous hopefully she's making some
money and she's doing big things what i
was really disappointed in is that like
they gave her that 30-day
what was it like a ban and that meant
she couldn't run like the one
really she was like really passionate
about but she did qualify for other
events that happened after the 30-day
ban
but then the olympic team
committee didn't choose her even though
she was eligible and i just felt like
that wasn't cool yeah no that it's tough
it's tough and but you know what she's
still getting opportunities i think it
sucks that she doesn't get to do what
she dreams of but
hopefully she'll still stay out of there
and have another opportunity on the road
and you know everything happens for a
reason so this might set her on a really
exactly beautiful path objection may set
her up for something bigger exactly i'm
sensing a theme here today tyler
yes um well i will be listening to this
album i'm really hoping
we reported yesterday that people who
were at the album listening party said
there wasn't
any kind of lyrics or innuendos
negatively towards kim which makes me
really happy because
they're still a family you know that's
good it's mature but it's also like
you're writing about you can't be
writing about your mom or your kid's mom
right exactly so i think i think it's a
mature stuff for kanye which we haven't
always seen
which is good yeah i would be really sad
if he was just like out here like how he
did to taylor swift are you still dating
the other model so i've heard
conflicting reports in the mainstream
media they are saying
yes him and irena shake are still
together but you know the underground
uh blind item dumois there's conflicting
reports but according to
legitimate owl it's yes is doom off
factual um
i have been on juma a few times and
they're constantly lying on my name
um but i do think for the most part it's
somewhat factual yeah do you read
tomorrow i'm not my b have stuff sent to
me about democracy you're always on it
yeah i'm like i wasn't even on the west
side highway and there you go yeah i
spotted running over there i was like no
no well i do think that jumoi posts like
a few days late so if like she put
something on wednesdays
about you running on the west side
highway which does sound like something
you would do
but i haven't even been in new york oh
okay okay okay well that that's fair
because sometimes she's delayed but
sometimes
i don't know when it was but yeah yeah
so where do you run
set the record straight to democracy
where jupiter florida
jupiter florida is that where you live
full-time pretty much now yeah
and you still have a place here that you
share with i do you're
brother matt james yes my my little big
brother matt james
yeah and uh yeah it's been quite a ride
for matt james he has he's he's been
through a journey but he's a journey
he's doing well he's doing well and have
you met rachel
i have rachel's great she's stunning
yeah she's beautiful girl she's sweet
she's fun and they're happy
love to see that love to see that
alright next story
i know you're dying dying to know what
mindy kaling has to say about the
legally blonde three update
she's writing the script this is
incredible mindy kaler
yes tyler c read the stories he did his
homework
um and mindy kaling went on watch rapids
live last night rhys witherspoon round
three
jennifer uh what's her name coolidge
could feel like the fourth of july okay
so mindy kaling is writing the script
which is
so fabulous and she went on watch it
happens live last night and andy cohen
of course
always asking the pertinent questions
the things that people want to know
he's amazing so on tuesday watch robin's
live with andy cohen
kaylin was asked to tease the project by
answering a series of questions
she noted that she's still working on
the first draft of the script with
witherspoon
she also shared that the most
intimidating part of the project is just
capturing the voice and also things like
the vengeance snap
yes exactly do you know how to bend and
snap yeah well you do have to stand but
it's more of just like a ooh
and then like this really very well done
um
she also notes that there's an actual
snap yes of course bend oh no there is
not an actionable snap she like snaps
her wrists
yeah so it's more of an emotional snap
okay
i'm learning bend and snap um
she also really fans are curious
obviously about how jennifer coolidge is
going to be
involved in the project she played
paulette who was really an integral
character in
reese's development both i think
personally and professionally
so she's uh according to mindy kaling
quote a thousand percent gonna be
returning in this installment
and um i'm just i feel like the script
is in a good place
i'm curious how you feel about this
trend
how like no original shows or movies are
made anymore they just like reboot old
stuff make more sequels prequels
what are your thoughts on that i think i
think it's good because nostalgia
they're gonna get the old people you
know the people used to watch uh like
say
uh like it's gonna everyone who used to
watch the blue bomb one back to the
movie theaters and watching live on
three again so
not every movie is going to be for like
the new generation something's got to be
for the older generation
yeah and i think star wars had like 19
movies that's true are you
what what movies are you passionate
about like what
like i would say in terms of franchises
i would take a bullet for the cast of
twilight like
that's me you're nuts have you seen
twilight yeah
i saw i tried to watch like 30 minutes
of the movie like you go as like a kid
in middle school to go with the girl
doesn't know what i mean i think if you
appreciate true art and true love which
i think you do according to your book
from what i've gathered you do if i
appreciate if you appreciate true love
you'd watch the movie into the blue
paul walker jessica alba okay just
diving through the ocean
i'll watch that if you watch twilight
it's the most beautiful
romantic movie in the world do we have a
deal i'll watch it
we go we'll do it all right i'll watch
it no i never even heard of it oh my
gosh paul walker with a shirt off just
gabba
and a bikini best thing in the world
sounds like a movie i once saw called
blue crush
yeah no it's better it's better okay
well legally blonde three is coming
we are quaking and i feel very i feel at
ease that
it's in the hands of mindy kaling i
think she's a very like i'm not worried
about it being bad because maybe
i'm sure it's gonna be great um all
right next up a little dating news
because offset is
telling everyone that he lost ten
thousand dollars on his first date with
cardi b
so we went on jimmy kimmel and opened up
to the guest host with who was anthony
anderson
about the early days of his relationship
with cardi
he said my first date i went big i
wanted to do something that was not
normally done i wanted to have fun
and not be so serious and enjoy the time
so i took her to the super bowl
i lost ten thousand dollars at night but
you know what i won
my wife isn't that sweet that's
beautiful so i guess he's saying he'd
like bet ten thousand dollars on a game
on the game yeah
that's a lot of money it is a lot of
money it is a lot of money i was just in
vegas and lost two thousand dollars and
that hurt
crippling devastating you know him to
lose ten thousand dollars you know i
think he's all right
i think he'll be fine yeah that's like
one of his pinky rings what do you think
is an appropriate amount of money to
spend on a first date with someone
you're like really excited about or just
anyone on a first date just depends on
how you how big you want to do it you
know i think there's no
right amount of money is you know it's
just a grand gesture you know that's
true i think making romantic gestures
are important
you know uh that doesn't always mean
money it doesn't always mean money so it
could just be be creative be fun
you know go for it you know you don't
have to spend ten thousand i think
betting ten thousand dollars is like not
going to prove anything to that girl
no right i think that was more thank you
just happy to be on the super bowl this
is gonna be fun
my home team is playing i think it had
nothing to do with cardi b but
he turned it around to make it what is
the tyler c
template for a first date so this is
going to be against a lot of what people
believe in for first dates
i love going to dinner on a first date
yeah that's rough yeah because people
are like no you need to have an activity
you need to go for drinks whatever well
there's drinks involved
yeah but like what if it's atrocious and
then like the meal takes so long what if
the service is bad you can't get the
check like
and you literally just want to jump out
of the window yeah then you just
jump out the window and you run what are
your thoughts on like ditching on a
first date that's so right it's terrible
yeah i mean
you should you know if you're not
enjoying yourself you know step up to
the play and say hey this isn't it for
me like i'm sorry
i got to go home or have one of your
friends call you i have an emergency
and get out that's the best but uh but
for me i like to have
uh dinner on the first date because if
there's dead air in the conversation
it's probably not gonna work anyways
that's actually a really good point you
know like uh i saved my first date with
my
my girlfriend we said we sat there for
four hours and did not stop talking we
didn't even look at the menu we just
kept talking and the lady i just told
lady like just bring us whatever you
think is good
what restaurant i'm just trying to
imagine it's elizabeth italian
restaurant
how nice yeah and it clearly worked it
worked it worked and then we went for
drinks afterwards so we didn't get
enough of each other
wow and then then we saw each other more
what's your like after dinner date move
you know like one of these i go
huh i'm tired you know like trying to
get out of here or trying to like no
like trying to progress
oh i never tried to make a move on the
first date i don't think kissing on the
first date's a good thing
really yeah i don't i don't trust
experience traditional
yeah you know i try and then uh so what
date
so i'll tell you a funny story i tried
kissing on the second date and she
rejected me
and then man's rejection is god's
rejection
and then and then she's like no no no
you haven't showed me i was all right
and then i could have got butt hurt but
i was like i like this girl i'm going to
keep going and going and going and
i then i got trigger shy that was scared
to kiss her yeah of course and then the
ptsd
the fifth date i finally kissed her
fifth date wow
i got scared what do you think about
people who [ __ ] on the first date
uh hey if it works in the worst of them
and that's not everyone's going to have
you know the same
you know ways of doing things so if
that's the way you guys go and it works
out and blossom to a beautiful thing
right
so be it right i guess that's also just
like the takeaway every situation's
different every person is different
there's no like
rules yeah exactly but for me i just i
want i want to play it slow
you know talk see where it goes and go
from there and how long have you
have you and your gal pal been together
seven months wow and it's going well
it's going well
are you the marrying kind tyler say am i
the marion kind like do i want to get
married yeah yes
my biggest goal is i want to be a dad
and a husband and have family and kids
and all that
very interesting do you think you'll be
more of a girl dad or a boy dad uh
ideally i'll be i'll be whatever dad i
need to be
you're being a great dad to theo right
right now yeah you're actually being
more of like a boyfriend to theo but i
think he's okay with that
um all right next up some salacious news
out of the hamptons page six is
reporting that wealthy travelers
are starting bidding wars to score rooms
in the hamptons at hotels so i didn't
send you this story because it was a
last-minute edition but
i'll just give you the whole play by
play the hamptons are so overbooked this
summer some folks are offering hotels
way more than the going room rates to
score reservations the source tells page
six
so michael pitznosis who's the owner of
naya at the capri hotel in southampton
which i actually went to recently and it
was completely empty so i don't know if
i believe him
um he said it's like the hamptons have
gone wild
it's so it's it's wild out here these
days it's nearly impossible to get a
hotel room on weekends
in advance let alone getting them the
same day
and it says here right now that a lot of
the demand coming from
the hamptons is people wanting to see uh
you matt james and rachel kirk connell
riding skateboards throughout the
hamptons
so what do you have to say an official
comment i don't understand the hamptons
okay
okay i was just there we also got rained
down the whole time so
were you there july 4th i was there
memorial day weekend me too also so much
rain
yeah and uh but like we stayed at the
beach lodge which is like
you know beautiful place i'm like this
is like i heard so much about the beach
lodge of like
surf lodge oh i'm like what's the beach
lodge oh yeah
yeah this is this is the spot yeah the
thing with hotels especially in montauk
is that
almost every single one of them is
technically a motel and they're
understand that going in yeah no it's a
culture shock was that your first time
it was still very pretty and like
and they did a great job with the space
they have but i was expecting this huge
grand
hotel all these things and i walked up
and i'm like this is
montauk you know montauk is at its
essence it's like very small beach town
and it's been overrun over the last
couple years with people from the city
and now because of covet everyone's like
so desperate for a good time
everyone is running to the hamptons
every single weekend especially montauk
so was that your first time that was my
i wanted to cut jog which is like the
other
yeah that's beautiful yes quiet that's
beautiful we were staying at my buddy's
house they have a ton of money it was
the coolest house
one of the coolest i've ever been in so
that was great um but
you know i live by the beach in jupiter
i'm gonna keep my beach down there yes
it's probably more civilized down there
yeah yeah it's a little bit
around the beach down there what'd you
say so we know how to act around the
beach yes yes yes
um i haven't just remembered something
okay during quarantine you
were in a house in the beginning yes
what was it called like the quarantine
house is that what it was called
sporting crew
pointing crew yes and you know me and
jackie spoke about it a lot because you
guys are having so much fun
but it appeared as though no one was
ever taking out the trash
and and it did kind of bother us
because you know it's boys and girls and
you're living in close quarters and
you're dancing
and you're having fun but no one's taken
out the trash
the trash piled up the trash still like
it's like it happened so quick now
uh you know but like then we had like
nine people eight people in the house at
all times
and it was like a little 1300 square
foot house right so i mean three
bedrooms it was it was chaos
right and the trash you can confirm was
very rarely taken out trash was
taken out probably once or twice a day
but that's how quick things were
happening oh my god what were you guys
eating
i mean think about all the massive fears
a lot of people yeah me my brothers you
have matt brown bear all these guys
you know so it was it was a lot of
mouths to feed a lot of trash being and
guys aren't the best at keeping things
in order you know i think that's the
first statement
you know you should see the house now i
got everyone out of there whose house
was it
was it a rental was it your house oh
this is my house interesting okay
but now you feel like you've kind of
cleansed the energy yes i got a lot of
stuff
out of there you know what i mean like
so this also adds to the trash is
everyone sends all their pr boxes to you
that's very fair it's literally
christmas every morning
with hannah brown who at the time was
just off the dancing with the stars
so it was a million and one things there
yeah and so like as soon as you open
something up there's more trash and more
trash and
you know like the little kernels
everywhere yeah it was nuts the popcorn
the packaging popcorn
wow well i'm so glad we really cleared
that up that's been bothering me for a
while and i know jackie will be really
excited about it good good
um we have a little bit more pop culture
news brought to you by liquid iv
the hot summer months here are here and
we need to be proactive to keep our body
fueled and hydrated
and if you have a hard time drinking
water like i do then liquid iv
is a time saving item that you really
just need to stock up on
they hydrate you faster and more
efficiently than water alone liquid iv
contains
five essential vitamins more vitamin c
than are than an orange and it has as
much potassium as a banana
it is healthier than a sugary sports
drink there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives
and it has less sugar than an apple it's
made with clean ingredients non-gmo
vegan um and it's free of gluten dairy
and soy it's great for hydration
especially when it's super hot out
and also it's really great for a
hangover so take it before during after
you'll thank me later one stick of
liquid iv in a 16 ounce bottle of water
hydrates you faster and more efficiently
than water alone
and they're doing so much good they've
donated over 11 million servings of
liquid iv
globally and 4 million servings in
response to kovid19
they donate to hospitals first
responders food banks veterans
active military so you can spend money
knowing that your money's doing doing
some work
grab your liquid iv in bulk nationwide
at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use the code toast to
check out
that's 25 off anything you order when
you get better hydration today using
promo code toast at liquidive.com
all right wow this is
it's really fabulous it is good do you
get drunk tyler c yeah
you do yeah what's your beverage of
choice of course
what's your beverage of choice uh
smearing off aqua 21 number one flock of
flavor
yeah that sounds like a paid partnership
but i'm happy for you yeah
um our last story is a little business
news a little
tech news do you use venmo i do use
venmo
have you ever had like fans of the
bachelor or people who are
always finding yourself through your
memo yeah do they send you requests
uh colton's season yes they were going
through the venn row
and there's also a tick tock account are
you on tick tock yes
yes do you like it like you scroll it
really just like wait a long time
do you uh follow me can you follow me
back i'll follow you back thank you yeah
you'll be one of my seven fathers
how many um followers do you have i
think 900
000. 900. yeah i'm out here working so
hard for my 150 oh my god
um i haven't been dancing during
quarantine no i know but like the
dancing
let's talk about the dancing i'm so glad
you brought that up how do you remember
all the steps
i don't so first of all i i like look
back at him like what was i
doing i'm like i'm like i look like such
an idiot but i'm like there was nothing
to
was nothing to do with that we don't
blame you tyler everyone was on it and i
and like like my girlfriend now makes so
much fun of me for it you know what i
mean
as she should yes and it's so funny to
look back on i'm like yo we were in such
a crazy place at that point
emotionally you did yeah and like i mean
we were just having fun with it
you know what kind of stupid concepts or
ideas we come up to now but now i'm just
like the world's back to normal somewhat
i'm busy again you're no longer dancing
i'm no longer dancing
but maybe i'll be dancing soon yes on
this with the stars
no no no why not would you ever do
dancing with the stars
i'm just just so sad i'm gonna be
dancing soon he's gonna be dancing soon
okay wait like
okay i'll spiral after this so i can
think about what that means um okay so
venmo is having a little bit of an
update they're getting rid of one of
their most
recognizable features and in my opinion
one of the worst features
venmo's getting rid of the feed that
shows users payments to strangers
it's part of a drastic redesign that's
rolling out in the coming weeks
the mobile payment app which is owned by
paypal which i found to be really
interesting
announced the changes on tuesday
explaining that getting rid of the
global feed is part of its ongoing
efforts
to continually evolve the venmo platform
moving forward users will only see
payments between
friends when they open the app okay i've
always thought it's so bizarre how like
i could open my venmo i won't know a
single person on i'm like who the [ __ ]
are these people and what is it
connected to like i'll see some random
person from high school i'll be like how
do you know that i know that person
yeah who comes up on youtube
no i don't even know so here's what i
think it's going to affect only
okay the police the police the police
because like
the thing about i feel like all the drug
deals go on
that's actually a really good point so
the police aren't gonna be like no like
okay this guy puts
a ski emoji in july this guy's not
skiing in july
like the police aren't gonna know where
to go i just want to say if you've ever
bought drugs on venmo i don't think
there's a stupider thing that you could
do like talk about
leaving a paper trail exactly the thing
about drugs that you pay with cash
yeah of course um that's a very
interesting take
i wasn't expecting that but i'm so glad
you brought that up the police are gonna
be struggling now i also just feel like
venmo needs to stop trying to be like a
social media platform like it's a
platform
to send and receive money like i really
don't care
even though sometimes it's interesting
to see like married couples like
splitting dinner bills that's pretty
fascinating
you see that yeah of course wow yeah so
here's like someone charging someone for
like one drink seven dollars like you
just buy your friends
there's tea to it yeah cash up has no
tea to it so that's why cash ups not as
cool
but there's tea i'm like i don't care
that my literal like random friend from
camp 11 years ago and her husband split
dinner like that's interesting but i
would like to see like
does tyler charge his girlfriend for
dinner you know that's what i would like
to say
you should be able to follow celebrities
on venmo and see like what
because in the real housewives of
beverly hills they were to supermarket
one time and teddy mellencamp paid for
all the groceries and then she like
venmoed all the women which i thought
was weird because like your dad's john
mellencamp just pick up the grocery bill
but that's what i find interesting and i
would love to follow
celebrity finances maybe maybe that's a
new thing you do what's your most recent
venmo transaction
i i haven't i haven't been mowed all my
ubereats is connected to memo you can
see what i'm eating
oh what do you eat uh i had i had a
fungal last night yeah that's a puerto
rican
uh cuisine yeah yeah where where did you
get it from just some place around me
dominican cuisine i think it's called
interesting yeah wow what do you like to
eat tyler
everything everything okay but so if you
were on an island hypothetically i was
on an island i always need a restoration
hardware burger
every day and i'd survive so a burger a
burger do you think you could ever go
like meat-free
i think i could in time in time right
now having too much fun eating it
yeah of course like barbecuing now i'm
grilling so like yeah not now
in jupiter and jupiter i don't know if
you know this and i'm just trying to i
want you to walk out of here with the
most
possible pop culture and like
information
jupiter is really important to me yeah
because that is where
luan de la sapps was supposed to be the
night she got arrested in palm beach
and she got arrested for drunk and
disorderly conduct and that kind of
spiraled this journey for her
where she thought she needed to get
sober and currently she is sober it's
been a long journey for her to get there
but she was supposed to go visit her
brother in jupiter and literally the
night before she was in palm beach and
she like stumbled into the wrong hotel
room
wasted got arrested and then like
resisted arrest and
i think she like attacked a police
officer so in case you're ever wondering
why jupiter florida is historically
significant
that's why that's why not burt reynolds
no
that's why i got it and technically it's
a global story because luann de lesseps
is a countess
her family who is luanne i'm so glad you
asked okay
so you know what the real housewives of
new york is right yes so luann de la
sapps was one of these
bethany yes very good okay so and her
and
luanne have gone at it for years are
they friends now i don't think so
so luanne luanne would join the show as
a countess her husband was count
deliceps a very prestigious family from
france we got pause
what does count test count oh it's like
duke duchess how many chicken tenders
are in my basket make sure i got them
all
it's a title in british aristocracy so
that she comes
her husband came from a long line of
aristocrats
her family was well his family was
responsible for building the suez canal
so it was kind of a big deal that she
was on the show and this lovely
townhouse and he was never around
um but then they got divorced and she
decided to keep the name
countess the title i would yeah of
course
and she kind of whenever she's asked
about it because they're like you're not
really a countess
she says well queen latifah is not a
queen and lady gaga is not a lady
so honestly she made a good point so
she's been on the show now for like 10
years and it's kind of been this fall
from grace from her she was like one of
the wealthiest housewives shields in a
townhouse on the upper east side
a huge house in the hamptons then they
got divorced
and then she was like living in this
cottage in sag harbor and then like
rental one bedroom in the city it got
dark for a minute
but she came out on the other side of
her arrest in palm beach when she was
supposed to be headed to jupiter
and she's kind of um so jupiter made her
better
it made her worse before it made her
better exactly but that's life i've been
there too in jupiter at that moment
i've been there too like in my bedroom
um okay
next up today's wednesday all right and
wednesday is the day well actually we
moved it to tuesdays but i wanted to do
with you so we moved it back to
wednesday for this week
dear toasters you're so special um our
advice segment you can always write in
dear toasters
gmail.com and today tyler's going to
give out his best advice for some of our
toasters who are
going through shall we say a difficult
time okay
and the deer test toaster segment is
brought to you by movement
movement watches i know you have one
i've seen it on your instagram in a tiny
apartment in southern california two
college drops
don't show me teamed two college
dropouts
teamed up to create a watch company that
broke all the rules with fair prices
unexpected colors and clean original
designs movement grew into one of the
fastest growing watch brands shipping to
over 160 countries across the globe
now movement has expanded into blue
light glasses that protect your eyes
from screens
minimalist jewelry and more style
essentials that don't break the bank
all designed by their california
headquarters and movement is celebrating
their eight year anniversary on july
20th by running a huge site-wide sale
everything is 28 off that's 28 of all
their best-selling watches blue light
glasses jewelry and more
the quality is unmatched and there are
modern watches for a fair price they're
super durable as well
and their sunglasses come with uv rated
polarized lenses
and they're going all out for their
eighth birthday so if you've been
wanting to get something this is their
biggest sale of the year take advantage
celebrate eight years of movement with
28 off site-wide
that's mvmt.com toast to enjoy that 28
off that's 28 off site wide at mvmt.com
toast okay here is our advice people
people are quaking they need you tyler
hi claudia and jackie well hello claudia
and tyler thank you for being the laughs
and positivity in my damn match so
welcome
i'm writing you live from my childhood
bedroom tonight my boyfriend of eight
years came home from work and told me
that he wasn't happy
we are high school sweethearts went
through college together have lived
together for two years
and we just resigned a two-year lease
together and even have a dog
him telling me this comes as a total
shock to say the least long story short
my parents came to pick me up from
our house and i came home i told him i'd
come home for dinner this weekend and we
could talk about our next steps
he promised me he would not break up
this weekend during dinner
i literally love this man with my whole
heart and really want this to work
we've never had a problem like this in
our relationship and i feel totally
blindsided
what do i do now do i go friday and say
i'll move out for a month
he's my best friend and i really thought
i'd marry him please help i really don't
want to tell my friends yet until
something is figured out
sincerely a weeping toaster that's
really sad tyler
that's sad it's tough so so here's i
have two things one
sometimes you need some time yeah what i
mean space to figure out what you need
but here's my second thing i think he's
not happy because what's the next steps
they've just been doing the same thing
now forever ever and ever
yeah like they need to take the next
step high school college
high school college now they're living
together like what are you waiting on
yeah you know but also i think you need
a little
you need a little judge because at the
end of the day
and i know it's easier said than done
obviously like i don't think you want to
be with someone who doesn't want to be
with you
of course and it sounds like
you're maybe hanging on to something
that's
been over for a while yeah and just
because he's
may not be happy with himself doesn't
mean he's not happy with you that's true
he's got to do some slow searching she's
got to do some soul searching i think
she knows where she wants to be
yeah he's got to figure out where he
wants to be um
i will always say this though the grass
is not green on the other side and that
guy could be thinking that
but it's really not it's only green
where you put the water yeah and so
you know i hope you know he comes to his
senses and and finds that this is where
he wants to be you already spent so much
time
but i think it's time for them to start
progressing and take the next steps and
start thinking about what life is
together instead of just like doing
day-to-day stuff doing the same thing
from high school
yeah yeah no that's a really good point
but also know your worth like if
someone's like trying to get rid of you
like bye like
exactly you may deserve better yeah no
and i don't like people like you want to
be around me go [ __ ] yourself i'm
awesome so are you
all right next up dear claudia and tyler
we have a workplace situation
okay well not a workplace situation any
longer but a potential romance that
started within the office walls
i had a flirty relationship with a guy
in another department for roughly a
month
when he put in his notice that he had
accepted a job elsewhere the
relationship turned a new leaf
on his last day at the job we celebrated
with a few rounds of drinks
and ended up returning to the office for
a late night smooch
and sleepover at the office yes
the romance was fun and potentially
something i could see a future in
he then asked me to go on a date the
following weekend which included drinks
and a movie
i said in a carefree and not so serious
manner that he could venmo
me for the tickets and the snacks 48
hours later
much to my shock a 20 venmo request came
through
i'm now fully rethinking the romance is
this acceptable because i offered
is it atrocious as i feel it is um a
fact to keep in mind is that
um i'm 30 he's 27. help a girl out is
the venmo request the kiss of death on
this relationship
um she memo'ed him he sent her a request
oh he said after the date even though
she was like well if you want to send me
a venmo like let me know and then he did
like a day later oh man
shouldn't have offered okay first of all
but he's also
younger he's younger she should have
never said that of course right
second of all guys we can't do this we
gotta step up we gotta pay the bill we
gotta
you know like do the right thing you
know of course you know like
to me i have a like this is my belief
when i'm dating someone i'm with
somebody
it's my investment into the relationship
too it's like it's like it's me going
off i don't need you to put you know
i'll say if i need money if i'm down and
out then maybe help me out but
there's a difference between being cheap
and being poor yeah
and being cheap is the worst thing you
can do especially when you're trying to
court someone exactly
so it's all about how you act and if and
i think
it would be better to go on a date
that's less expensive than to go on
something you can't afford and send
someone a venmo request exactly like for
instance like i have a friend who's
trying to become a college coach or nfl
coach the starting pays is you're broke
right you don't make any money you know
and he's got an amazing girlfriend and
she helps with something of course
you know and but you know she knows like
when it's time he's going to step up
yeah but that's a relationship that's
that's like the poor not cheap part
right but like i think this guy's just
being cheap i mean they work together
they're in the same department so they
have similar salary
it sounds like you have a nice job you
got a new job at a new place like
you probably got paid a little bit more
yeah a bonus so i don't think i don't
think it's a kiss of death
but like this guy might be a cheap ass
and this guy might suck
yeah honestly like i don't feel very
good about it yeah and
um let's let's just give him the x
yeah i think like don't waste your time
what are your thoughts
you're done with oh my god yes i love
that you use the gavel we're serving
justice
justice in the court sir sir we like to
do it over here it's a little loud yeah
it doesn't feel as good you're scared
stop please oh my god you scared the
[ __ ] out of me
um the other thing i was gonna say was a
question for you at what point in the
relationship does it then become like
normal to like split stuff like
you're in a relationship or do you do
you think the man in a heteronormative
relationship like a guy should pay
for the girl like up until they get
married like when does that end
i don't remember i see i have a very
traditional look on this like
wait i was raised my dad and everything
like i'm going to take care of you i'm
going to take care of the kids i'm going
to take care of everything i can you
know what i mean you're going to take
care of me and whatever you do
whatever you bring in there's like
whatever you want to bring in right like
but like to me i think the most
important job in the world is to be
a parent a grade and to be a mom and so
like if you want to be a mom
or if you want to work and be a mom like
it's whatever you want to do i'm never
going to argue that but i know my
intentions
is i'm going to try and provide for
myself for you and for the kids and
everything in the future
you know so i'm going to try and take
care of everything i appreciate that
all right final one before we let tyler
go
theo's devastated i just want to point
out how you and theo have been holding
hands
yeah the entire time and it's so sweet
he's gonna be devastated when you walk
out of here i'm taking him with me and
he's also able to
i have a shoot next okay i use him for
my shoot 100 does he get paid for fly
first class
i'm not even getting paid theo knows
theo knows what a suitcase is and it
really triggers him because it means
like yeah and so when you leave here
with
he has a suitcase he's going to be
devastated he's going to yelp i'm
telling you
all right final one hello claudia and
tyler um
i need your help i've been dating my 25
year old boyfriend for two and a half
years now and i moved in with him eight
months ago
since i moved in with him it has become
apparent that he
that he severely lacks based basic
hosting slash
guest etiquette most recently he and i
were invited to our friend's apartment
for a movie night i suggested we bring
spike seltzers
intending to give them to the host upon
arrival while i finished getting ready
he packed up the drinks and we had it
over when we get there
sorry he plops the bag with the seltzers
onto their countertop
reaches in and grabs a drink for himself
not only did he not give the drinks to
the host
i realized he had packed the already
open box of seltzers
that we had as opposed to the fresh
unopened box i had intended for him to
bring
mortified and not wanting to draw
attention to my boyfriend's misbehavior
i played it off as if i hadn't noticed
we watched the movie and when it was
finished we started getting our things
to head home
as i'm putting my shoes back on i see
him he grabs he grabs the salters
oh my god as i'm putting my shoes back
on i see him reach into the host's
fridge
grab the leftover seltzers that he
brought and put them in our bag
when we left i told him this is not
appropriate guest behavior but he
thought it was not a big deal
because it was a casual movie night am i
overreacting or does my boyfriend have
no manners please let me know your
thoughts your advice is
much needed sincerely an embarrassed
toaster that's
so funny and that's bad like there's
nothing worse than people who aren't
like
good home guests don't offer to help
clean up don't bring a gift
so i hear you and i think this is really
inappropriate and i think
you're not overreacting at all i would
be mortified if ben did that
it's definitely inappropriate it's
definitely not good but the guy needs to
sometimes the guy's a little rough
around the edges yes you got to polish
them up a little bit teach them these
things
shouldn't be your job yes but sometimes
you have to and
it's got it's important if he's willing
to learn and receptive to it if he's not
then you gotta
get rid of them you stop
oh my god it's so loud we're gonna get
noise complaints um i agree with you i
think in a lot of
straight men a lot of work needs to be
done
think of the man you were when you were
18. how do you feel you're different now
tyler
even the man i was at 25. how old are
you uh i'm 28 now geez
wow uh yeah but you know if i was is
like they bring
shelters like i would bring wine to
someone's eyes yeah what i mean but it's
that's also like a lifestyle thing like
some people seltzers are i mean
you talk a lot of [ __ ] for someone
wearing a white cloth shirt it's not a
white closure
it's a skateboarding company it's a
white claw logo it's a skateboarding
company
i'm just saying seltzer's seltzers are
good i like shelters
yeah me too what's your shelter of
choice they're dangerous truly i like
truly's they have good flavors like
smearing off seltzers
yeah they're good ones i actually had a
smart enough seltzer like
a week ago just because it was the only
thing in the fridge but it was pretty
good
it was good i put it in with a little
tequila it was pretty good you spice it
up a little bit
um are you a tequila or a vodka drinker
if you had to choose
anything clear i'm good with so i like
vodka i like tequila i like gin
so it's clear that anytime i ask you a
question you have some sort of paid
partnership so i'll stop asking
questions about alcohol
because well barry's over there look at
her
oh my oh [ __ ] sorry barry um okay well i
just have to say i've so enjoyed getting
to know you on a deeper level i hope
that you leave here
with not only a love for thea which i
think is unmatched um a greater
understanding of
you know pop culture pop culture yeah
and i hope now maybe
you're going to the airport grab a
people magazine you wanna hear my pop
culture story
do i want to hear your pop culture story
i'm assuming it's not about gigi hadid
but yeah continue
sorry her name
what what's the girl's name who's in
mean girls lindsay lohan
tina fey tina fey tina fey yeah so i'm
with
like like i don't think it was you but i
forgot what agents we were with we were
in
an elevator in l.a and tina fey was in
the elevator and everyone's like
you know you obviously did i'm over here
probably picking
and she gets out of the elevator and
everyone's like oh my god you know what
it is i was like no they're like that's
tina fey i'm like who's tina fey
and they're like you don't know who tina
fey is 30 rock no
do you watch tv not really you know i
watch oh i watch dirty john
have you watched it that's what you
watch
dirty john season one is crazy well i'm
you know i'm glad that's on bravo so
that's the same network
yeah that was like one of a few scripted
shows they did that
that and that show that was the host of
what
architecture great show about i thought
that was on quibby
it wasn't quite but it's brought to you
by bravo it's about this guy
strong muscles it was your show yes oh
yeah you were building houses for dogs
right yeah yeah and you never
offered to make the open we didn't make
it to the east coast yet you know yeah
we got cancelled
okay which famous dogs did you make
houses for on that show uh we did uh
tiana taylor's dog did you know who she
was yes i knew who she should have
i like her music yeah oh we did kyle
richards real housewives
yes beverly hills she has a lot of dogs
she's super cool
which dog all of them we made a massive
house a mansion
uh it was like a dog mansion for sure um
we did
uh the vanderpump more more reality
television yeah we don't she didn't
do that she thought i was a coffee
person shut up
she had no idea who i was and what i was
doing what did she ask you for
a lot of time she just looked at me she
was like what are you doing i'm like
crying i'm actually the host of the show
and so that was interesting uh who else
was that we did uh joel mchale
oh cool did you used to watch the soup
uh i watched episodes before i went to
school so i knew what i was doing out of
respect of course of course of course
but joel mchale was cool he was super
cool but like he's a he's a comedian and
so he just so out in the left field i
have no idea what he's talking about
while i'm trying to ask him so what do
you want this house to look like he's
talking about some floating river
over here and all this stuff i'm like
joel like focus you know yeah
and uh who else we did lily sing that
was cool that was a cool house
uh but yeah you know the show's
cancelled so we don't talk about it
anymore no that sounds like a really
exciting
show it's on roku now yes
oh demi lovato is gonna have a new show
on roku the demi lovato show i can't
wait to not watch it mike johnson's
guess
oh wait no he's not oh you know what
what do you think about this trend i
guess it really started with sarah
highland and wells of people coming off
the bachelor and dating celebrities i
mean you really kind of took the trophy
but
i i don't think the trend is going on
anymore i mean i guess mike johnson kind
of ruined it for everyone yeah
freaking mike freaking mike do you think
he should have been the bachelor i think
he would have made a great bachelor let
me tell you you know i think we've all
had great ones ever since
i don't know if i would agree with that
i think i think a lot of a lot of
americans trying to be pc i think a lot
of americans would
literally like to have their brains
removed after watching peter's season
yeah i was gonna i was gonna put i mean
if you just watch his instagram
sometimes you'll need your brain
i mean his tick tock honestly somebody
needs to take his phone away barb needs
to take his phone away do you still
watch about her
i have not yet ever since matthews and i
have not kept up got it but you watched
matt's
yeah i watched a little bit matt so much
drama it was a lot a lot a lot of juice
um okay well that's really all the
questions i had for you
um i so want to thank you for being here
everyone make sure to check out tyler's
book it comes out january 27th it's
called you deserve better
27th next week july is that what i said
yeah that's when my book came out uh
july 27th
what life has taught me about love
relationships and becoming your best
self you look very handsome on the cover
was this taken in jupiter this was
taking miami oh
heading north i think um south
and there's little pictures in the
middle that's you and your mom i won't
spoil it but that's a really cute
picture
and you look so different that's when i
was a baby i was like a sophomore in
high school there
you get like a face transplant or
something no you look so different
still handsome but just different um
check it out available audiobook ebook
amazon all the places um you deserve
better by tyler cameron
tyler thank you for being here um thank
you for having me theo
is never gonna be the same no and it's
been an absolute pleasure hanging out
with you today and you guys as well
happy humpty thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
and youtube so if you're watching this
on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so it's spotify itunes citra
public radio i already cast box all the
places where you listen to the podcast
find out morning shows leave five star
you better beautiful sounding and smart
we are
have an amazing hump day make sure to
hump someone you love i'm gonna hum theo
consensually and i will see you guys
tomorrow for our final
in studio show we have a special guest
co-host somebody people have been
requesting for a while and then friday
we're podcast only we're checking with
jackie on her vacation so we'll see you
tomorrow morning
bye